All right, let's jump right in.
Today on the Deep dive, we're
tackling something that's really
made some waves, a piece called
Editing when the Board Turns
Red.
It's one of those reads that
well, it kind of flips your
understanding of war, surrender,
and even what it means to be a
victim in a conflict.
Our mission today is pretty
straightforward.
Pull out of the key ideas, the
important Nuggets from the
single source.
Think of this deep dive as maybe
a shortcut, a way to get really
well informed on something that
frankly effects how we see
global events happening right
now.
The author's view is, well, it's
stark, unromantic, pretty brutal
actually.
And they use these really
compelling analogies, chess,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu, to make
their point.
So we'll dig into the core
arguments, look at how it
redefines things we take for
granted.
And you know what this all means
for you watching the world
stage.
It's fascinating, isn't it, how
the source just trips away all
the the moral language we
usually hear around conflict
really forces you to look at a
more basic, almost primal logic,
a kind of detached reality that
can be, well, uncomfortable.
Our goal here is just to lay
that framework out clearly for
you, connect the dots, show the
implications.
And let's be super clear up
front, we're not pushing any
political view here, not
justifying anything.
We're just exploring the ideas
in the source, trying to
understand the author's
perspective on these dynamics,
which does raise a big question
for us and for you listening.
How much of how we see war is,
you know, idealized, maybe even
romanticized versus this sort of
detached reality the author
keeps talking about?
It challenges you to look past
the headlines, doesn't it?
It absolutely does, and that
challenge starts like right away
with the first big idea, the
nature of war itself.
The source uses this line that
just grabs you.
There is a point on every
battlefield, physical or
diplomatic, where the piece you
were playing stops being a piece
and starts being neat.
Wow.
I mean, that's a visceral image
right from the get go.
The core idea?
It's stark.
War isn't polite.
It's brutal design the author
says to be an atrocity.
And they give these vivid,
almost gut wrenching examples.
A trench line in Donbas.
A music festival tent near Gaza.
A village you thought you could
hold forever with an AK and a
prayer.
These aren't just points on a
map, the author stresses.
They become places of extreme
suffering, destruction.
And this immediately bumps up
against our modern ideas.
You know, clean wars, precision
strikes, the source seems to
say.
Well, maybe those concepts are
distractions.
Maybe they sanitize something
fundamentally unavoidable about
conflict.
Yeah, it's like the author
saying that language hides the
real cost of admission to using
force.
Exactly.
And if we connect that to the
bigger picture, the source flat
out says all war is atrocity by
design.
If it weren't, it wouldn't be
war, it would be chess with tea
and biscuits.
That's a key distinction they're
making.
It's just the purpose of war is
to inflict suffering to damage,
to achieve some goal.
The atrocity isn't a bug, it's a
feature.
In the moment.
You choose force, you pick up
the rifle or the rocket or the
diplomatic Sabre, you're
basically signing up for this
ancient contract.
You break it, you buy it, you
swing, you get swung at.
So when the author says domain a
force, that's the switch from
talking to fighting.
Pretty much it's when
negotiation stops and raw power
coercion takes over.
You picked up the weapon,
whatever it is, and once you're
there, the rules change.
Or maybe it's less rules and
more unforgiving realities.
It's really rephrased.
Responsibility doesn't.
It yeah, it sounds like it.
Because the idea is, once you
decide to use violence, the
whole game changes.
It's not controlled anymore.
It's visceral, unforgiving.
It challenges the idea you can
sort of dip your toe into
conflict without getting hit
back hard.
That contract implies basically,
if you start or join the
violence, you accept violence
coming back at you.
It's not about moral
justification from the author's
view.
It's just cause and effect
within that domain of force,
action, reaction, primal stuff.
OK, so if war is fundamentally
this atrocity by design, that's
a really bleak starting point.
So how do you ever stop it then?
Where do things like, you know,
the Geneva Conventions, the laws
of war fit in?
And this is where the author
introduces another really
challenging idea.
They say the law of war only
really kicks in when you embrace
resignation, the sacred nature
of resignation.
That feels deeply uncomfortable.
I imagine a lot of people would
push back on that.
It almost sounds like it removes
that safety net we think the
rules provide.
It does sound like that
initially.
But the author uses these
powerful analogies to make it
clear.
Think about chess.
Your kings cornered.
Checkmate is obvious.
You don't keep shuffling pieces
around hoping the rules change,
right?
No, you tip it over.
Good game.
No blood, no broken teeth.
Resignation is sacred,
dignified.
It stops pointless damage or
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
You tap.
Out right you tap before the arm
breaks.
Exactly.
Tap before the arm snaps or the
choke closes the trachea, You
live to fight again.
So these analogies, they point
to a principle.
Recognize you're beaten, yield,
survive, get a future, even if
it's a future under tough terms.
It's about accepting the outcome
before total destruction,
prioritizing survival.
And this leads directly to what
the source calls a weird moral
mutation on the world stage.
The author describes it like
this, the belief that you can
throw a punch, take a punch
back, realize you're losing, and
then freeze the game by
screaming genocide or war crime
at the ceiling while your other
hand reloads the rifle behind
your back.
Wow.
OK, that's.
Blunt it is blunt and, the
source says, flat out doesn't
work that way.
It's basically saying moral
outrage can't just pause a fight
you're losing, especially if you
plan to keep fighting.
Once you're in that domain of
force, the author argues, the
moment to wave the white flag is
always there, but you have to
wave it.
You have to actually do it.
Right.
The implication is those
international laws of war, they
often only fully bind the other
side when you genuinely stop
fighting.
If one side keeps swinging, the
other side in this framework is
not only permitted but compelled
to swing until you stop moving
or yield.
That's a really hard line.
It's very direct, very
challenging.
It suggests that accusations of
war crimes or genocide, which
are incredibly serious things,
are sometimes used tactically,
used to try and stop a bad
military situation, not as a
real end to hostilities or
admission of defeat.
And the author claims those
tactics just don't work in the
raw logic of force, because that
logic demands a clear end.
One side yields.
So if you really want the
suffering to stop, the path,
according to this source, is
surrender, not fighting on while
claiming victimhood and crying
foul.
It's a very cold take on
battlefield reality.
That split between the moral
claim and the the physical
reality of still fighting,
that's a huge shift in
perspective, and it connects
right into the next big concept,
proportionality.
We hear that word all the time,
but the source has a very
different, maybe even more
uncomfortable take.
The author says proportionality
is not a shield, it's a clock.
OK, not a shield, it's a clock.
What's the author really getting
at there?
Well, the core idea is pretty
stark, yeah.
There's no referee stepping in
mid fight to check if things are
proportional.
No instant replay review on the
battlefield.
Exactly, the author says the
referee comes after after the
fighting stops.
That's critical because we often
talk as if there is some real
time check right?
The West wrings its hands about
disproportionate response, but
the author says that's just
misunderstanding how force
works.
Totally misunderstanding it
according to this view.
And again, powerful analogies,
chess.
You don't hold back your queen
from taking a pawn because it
feels, you know, unfair or
disproportionate nature.
You don't tell the bear bite
less hard because the cub poked
at first once it's been provoked
and feels threatened.
Right, the response is about
neutralizing the threat.
The author says you act until
the threat is gone, or your
appetite is satisfied, and you
own the moral and material cost
afterward.
That's just a profoundly
different way to think about
engagement rules.
It's pragmatic, almost cold.
It sees the immediate goal and
conflict as just eliminating the
threat, full stop.
And the whole proportionality
discussion that happens later,
much later, after the dust
settles.
And what's really striking is
how the source applies this
directly to current events,
examples you'll recognize.
And again, this can be tough to
hear through this lens.
First, Russia and Ukraine.
The auto claims Russia's
invasion follows this principle.
They argue Russia played the
long quiet game for 30 years.
Watch NATO expand towards its
border.
Exactly.
And while doing that, Russia
built alliances like bricks,
made energy deals, position
itself.
And all along, the source says,
Russia sent one message.
Don't take Ukraine.
The author paints it as this
patient, strategic set up.
Then the chess clock ran out,
and the conclusion of the source
is chilling.
When the cheese wire was nearly
closed, the bear lunged.
Fair, legal, ugly.
The author says yes to all
three, but inevitable once the
chess clock ran out.
So the argument is it was a
strategic response to a
perceived threat reaching a
boiling point regardless of
immediate proportionality.
That's the argument presented.
It forces you to separate the
reason for the action as
perceived by the actor from the
moral judgement of it.
And similarly, the source looks
at Israel and Hamas especially
around October 7th.
Now, obviously incredibly
sensitive and we're just reeling
the author's argument here, not
taking sides.
Absolutely, just analyzing the
source.
The author states that before
that date, Israel wore the
muzzle, allowed scrutiny, kept
its claws dry, implying
restraint.
But then Hamas, weather baited
or genuine, tore the lock off
that muzzle on October 7th.
According to the author, that
act changed everything.
It invoked that ancient contract
of force.
The contract flipped.
Respond to lethal force with
overwhelming force.
And, the author adds, you can't
unspring that trap once you hand
the wolf the moral permission
slip.
So the implication from these
examples is pretty stark.
It's profound the source uses
them to argue military responses
are driven by eliminating the
threat or satisfying strategic
aims, not by some real time
fairness.
Check.
Proportionality gets judged
afterwards, if at all.
Not during the fight.
During the fight, the logic is
just when neutralize the threat.
All the talk about
disproportionate response that's
seen as postgame analysis
disconnected from the immediate
raw needs of combat.
It's a cold perspective
calculated, but the author
argues it's the detached
reality.
Okay, that now versus after
distinction for proportionality,
it really does shift how you
might think about things.
And moving beyond the
battlefield itself, the source
points to another, well, grim
truth, something that hugely
impacts how long a fight can
even last.
The limits of outside help, the
author says bluntly.
And backers don't bleed forever.
The core idea seems simple, but
crucial.
Allies, patrons, they aren't an
infinite well of support.
Their help is conditional.
It can dry up.
It often does.
It's strategic, not purely
altruistic.
Exactly.
It's an asset in a bigger game,
not some moral guarantee.
The source uses a great
historical example, the American
Revolution.
It reminds us the colonists
didn't win just because they
were brave farmers who outshot
the redcoats.
No, France played a huge role.
A decisive role, the author
argues.
France saw Britain's throat
exposed and handed the colonists
and Navy in cash.
And then the provocative bit.
If France had bailed when
Yorktown turned, we'd be
saluting the Union Jack.
It really underscores how
fragile that external support
can be.
It highlights the transactional
nature of it all, driven by the
backers interests.
And the source brings his right
up to today.
Current conflicts.
It says Ukraine is relearning
this.
NATO is not a forever battery
pack.
For a fight that looks
unwinnable, that suggests even
strong alliances have limits,
especially if a war drags on.
Without a clear path to victory,
the cost just becomes too high
for the backers.
Politically, economically right
and similarly, Hamas lives and
dies by how long Iran's drip
feed of cash and weapons stays
open.
It shows even non state groups
are totally dependent on these
life lines.
Life lines that come with
strings and limits.
The big take away here?
External support is about
advantage return on investment,
not endless kindness.
Absolutely.
And if we zoom out again, the
source puts it very starkly.
When your patron shrugs and says
good money after bad, the shell
dries up and the knife you hit
up your sleeve is suddenly just
a piece of scrap metal.
It's.
Harsh.
It's a brutal assessment of
alliances, isn't it?
It paints support as purely
transactional, based on value,
potential to success, strategic
gain for the backer.
It's a cost benefit calculation,
and cost isn't just money, it's
political capital, public
opinion back home, international
standing.
So there's always a tipping
point.
Seems so a point where the cost
outweighs the reward and the
support fades or just stops.
And that has huge implications
for anyone in a long fight.
It shows how fragile that
lifeline can be.
It's a reminder that you know,
moral support is one thing, but
long term military and financial
backing that often comes down to
cold, hard strategy.
Without that flow of resources,
your ability to fight can just
vanish, leaving you with
nothing.
A chilling thought that even
strong friendships might be
conditional in power politics.
OK, so let's tie these threads
together.
We've got war as atrocity by
design, the sacred resignation,
proportionality as a clock,
backers not bleeding forever.
It all paints a pretty bleak
picture for someone losing a
conflict, doesn't it?
When you're cornered, Rook gone,
King exposed.
What does the author say is the
detached reality?
What are the real choices it?
Sounds like the author sees only
two paths really, and only one
leads to survival, however grim.
OK, path 1.
Path 1 is you tap out resign.
Except the consequences.
Exactly.
Except the humiliations.
A lopsided treaty, loss of land,
occupation, blockade, sanctions.
Ugly, painful, humiliating.
Yes.
But, the author says
pragmatically, you seed your
children's future in the soil of
your surrender.
It's ugly, but it's survival.
So it prioritizes just
continuation, preserving
something, anything for the
future, right?
Versus path 2, which is path 2
is you keep pretending you can
win by crying victim while your
gun hand stays loaded.
Refusing to accept reality.
Pretty much, the source says
this only drags the game out.
The bear is not fooled.
The Wolf is not fooled.
The referee watches but won't
step in until you admit you're
done playing.
So continuing the fight based on
hope or moral appeals, the
author argues, that's
strategically disastrous.
Utterly ineffective in the
domain of force, according to
this view.
It just prolongs the suffering,
racks up the costs, and likely
leads to a worse, more complete
destruction in the end because
the basic fact being cornered
hasn't changed.
And the author seems completely
dismissive of like romantic
notions here.
Moral high ground doesn't help.
Zero romance involve.
The source states it baldly.
It's not romantic, it's not
moral, it's just game theory and
blood.
It emphasizes that the harsh
realities, especially end game
realities, are about cold
strategy and raw force, not
ethics or public opinion.
And here's a key line.
The mistake is confusing the
moral high ground with high
ground on the map.
One will not save you from the
other.
Wow, that distinction is
critical.
Moral arguments don't stop
bullets, essentially.
That's the core message.
The analysis is just relentless.
War is chess with live
ammunition.
That metaphor really sums it all
up.
Strategic, calculated, even when
it's brutal and bloody.
And the conclusion from that?
It's a harsh lesson, but maybe
pragmatic.
The best player resigns when
checkmate is inevitable.
Not giving up early, but seeing
the inevitable right?
Strategic foresight, recognizing
you can't win before total
destruction.
The best fighter taps before the
arm breaks.
Preserve yourself to fight
another day, maybe differently.
The best statesman cuts losses
early enough to salvage a
future, not stand defied for the
cameras while bodies pile up.
So it prioritizes ending the
suffering survival over symbolic
defiance.
Exactly.
It's a pragmatic call, and, the
author implies, until that
lesson is learned, until you
accept that cold logic, you're
just a pawn who refuses to lie
down wondering why the Queen
keeps coming.
That final image?
It's powerful.
The Queen keeps coming because
the game isn't over until you
yield or are eliminated.
Precisely.
It's not malice, it's the
objective of the game as defined
by force.
It frames continued resistance
in the checkmate situation as
futile self-destructive
guarantees, only more agony, not
a changed outcome.
The real wisdom, the source
argues, is seeing that finality
in choosing survival, even on
bitter terms, a tough lesson in
bragmatism.
So wrapping this up, what does
this all mean for you?
Listening, trying to make sense
of conflicts around the world,
We've really gone deep into a
perspective that it challenges a
lot of assumptions.
War as atrocity by design.
The hard truths about
proportionality, about external
aid.
The source argues that
understanding conflict means
stripping away the romance,
facing the cold logic of game
theory, the brutal results of
refusing to see checkmate.
It's a lens that tries to
explain the why in terms of raw
force, even if that explanation
is uncomfortable.
Yeah, and connecting it to the
bigger picture, what we've
explored today is a very
specific kind of relentless
framework for seeing conflict.
It pushes you to think
critically about the stories we
hear, the strategic choices
being made behind the scenes.
It really emphasizes recognizing
that detached reality versus the
moral high ground, suggesting
that while moral judgments are
vital later for accountability,
they don't often stop the
immediate fighting.
Only a real end to hostilities
does that, according to the
source.
Exactly.
So maybe the question for you to
ponder is this, in this world
flooded with information, with
really emotionally charged
narratives, how does
distinguishing between moral
high ground and high ground on
the map change how you
understand international events?
Could this framework help you
sort of cut through the noise?
Focus on the strategic realities
in different conflicts?
Yeah, it's a challenging
thought.
As the author says, it comes
down to recognizing that moment.
The moment where you either say
good game, sign the Armistice,
or accept what the board demands
when you don't.
Definitely something to consider
as you look at past conflicts,
current ones, and, well,
whatever comes next.
What does it really mean to cut
losses and what's the cost of
refusing?
Heavy stuff, but offers a kind
of stark clarity, maybe.